Nik wrote in david you talk about anti
and pseudo-intellectual ism often but
other than generally speaking it helped
helping elect Donald Trump what are the
impacts of anti intellectualism and
pseudo-intellectual ISM what aren't the
impacts right climate change pseudo and
anti intellectualism are directly
affecting our ability to really take
decisive action on climate change
because you have these so-called climate
skeptics who are against actually taking
action because they think the entire
thing is a hoax our relationships with
other countries this sort of harebrained
nationalism that we've seen prevents us
from actually taking steps that we
should take to better relationships with
certain countries and instead we're
focused on wouldn't it be lovely to be
friends with Russia or something like
that because people have been completely
bamboozled by the talking points of the
Trump administration because they can't
think for themselves what we're willing
to accept from our own leaders right the
pseudo intellectualism and anti
intellectualism that pervades our
country makes it so that we feel as
though much of what we see our leaders
do is just sort of normal when if we
really thought hard if we really thought
critically if we really informed
ourselves we would identify that the
many of the debates being had by our
elected officials are not even valid
debates and that gets more more broadly
just to the lack of critical thinking
skills in the country people are
influenced by really bad arguments or by
stuff that they think is evidence that
really isn't evidence when they can't
actually think for themselves and think
through problems in every way
the anti intellectualism in this country
is really damaging right and because
it's so widespread in our country it's
almost an argument against democracy in
a way and letting the elites be in
charge now I don't agree with that once
you have to win the day when the
arguments over and over again improve
our critical thinking and our media
literacy but it's just a very
unfortunate set of circumstance it
becomes circular because when you
identify that there are so many clueless
people who pride themselves on being
clueless who are as as is their right to
do voting and participating in our
electoral system that's how you
people saying should we have some kind
of a competency test for voting should
you only be allowed to vote if X which
of course is not the way our country was
found it is not something that would be
constitutional it's a disaster
but the degree to which we have these
uninformed individuals involved in our
political system is what gets people to
even consider something as
unconstitutional as a voting test which
of course I am against and Pat is also
against it's bad and I think that it's
also dunning-kruger is actually what
comes to mind the dunning-kruger effect
whereby someone lacks the cognitive
ability to recognize where they have a
cognitive deficit in other word that the
crude way of saying it is you're too
dumb to realize where you're being dumb
that's that's a completely crude way of
saying it you're not even really able to
explain to people why they're
anti-intellectualism is a problem
because they pride themselves on it and
believe that it's actually a good thing
it's bad it's really really bad out
there and Nick I don't know what the
solution is I certainly don't have one I
think that's clear yeah I mean it's a
horrible time to be a professor or an
expert in your field because you get
into debates with lay people on this and
they think they're just as qualified as
you are to speak about the again and we
actually that was an interesting part of
our interview last week with was it with
tom nichols yeah tom nichols about the
death of expertise and being able to
separate the fallacy of an appeal to
Authority with the reality that hey
there are people that know more about
certain things than you and it is
important to listen to them uh all right
well don't always have to agree with
them no you don't but you have to listen
to them I'm gonna get off my my ranting
now we've got a great bonus show coming
up for you and if you are not a member
this is it until 2018 because this is
the last regular show of 2017 but if you
remember then you do have one more bonus
show before we call it for the year